احمد البشير 25 سؤال لازم نجاوب عليه
بسرعه ومن غير تفكير مقدم برامج كوميديان
صحفي صانع محتوى مخرج اي وحده منهم فعليا
انت تعرف نفسك فيها مراقب
ليش ما بترجع للعراق
لاسباب فنيه طبعا فنيه امنيه يعني
ايش عندك حزن في حياتك
قليل يعني احاول انه اقول قليل اليوم من
يحكم العراق
هذا سؤال بدون تفكير
اللي يخطر على بالك على طول الديكتاتوريات
الصغيره المتوزعه واللي تدعي انه
الديمقراطيه كم مره تلقيت تهديد بالقتل
الفعليه اللي كانت خطيره حقيقه هي اثنين
الباقيه كذا يعني عادي على الماشي ايه يلا
اصعب موقف مر عليك في حياتك
لحظه وفاه اخويا كثير يعتبروك مناضل سياسي
هل تتفق
مرات احس انه الكرسي اللي انا قاعد عليه
اكبر من المسؤولين المفروض انحطت يعني انه
تحس انه ممكن ينطبق عليك مناضل يعني حطيت
بهاي الزاويه ما اقدر اقول انا اقرب الى
لانه ما عندي امل سياسي حقيقي اوكي طيب
عشا تعزم عليه ثلاثه سياسيين مين تختار
مش عارف الجبوري
موفق الرباعي
ونور المالكي
ايش معنى الاسماء اوكي مشعان لانه عنده
معلومات مهمه اسمعها من عنده موفق لانه
هواي يكذب فاريد اضحك ورا العشاء
مسوي البقايا
لو جينا نعمل جردل حياتك ايش تعتبر اهم
انجاز لك
انه قررت تقدم هذا البرنامج لو بيدك عصايه
سحريه وبامكانك تغيير شيء واحد في العراق
ايش تغير اول شيء تبدا فيه
هذا هو من هون
العاطفه قد العراقيين اقللها
هل لديك فكره هل لديك فكره لبرنامج جديد
مختلف في المستقبل طبعا
بدي برامج اجتماعيه وممكن برنامج سياسي
اخر طيب لو سالنا شريكه حياتك ايش ابرز
عيب فيك حتقول الكسل انت تقول ان المراه
افضل من الرجل بشكل عام ليش اداريا اقصد
من ناحيه اتخاذ القرارات تكون اقوى من
الرجل وبعده صفات اخرى بس الرجال زعاطيط
زعاطيط يعني يلعبون جيمز يعني الست مسؤوله
وقائده بطبعها اوكي عشر على عشره انت مفضل
عندي
طيب في انتقادات لبرنامجك انك حطيت
المحتوى السياسي على جنب وصرت تركز على
مقابلات وصفها البعض بالتافهة
قصه حبك مع زوجتك اوكي لو عرضوا عليك تسلم
وزاره عراقيه اي وزاره تختار
سلم وزراء
طيب سخريتك من الاشخاص اللي بتهاجمهم
احيانا يكون لها طابع شخصي هل تعتقد انه
هذا اخلاقي لا لا مو طابع شخصي ابدا هي
القصه تتعلق بفعله وليست هو كانسان انا
احترمه هو كانسان او احترمها مهما كانت بس
الفعل هو اللي يخليني اني اهاجمه بهذا
العنف
يعني لما يكون مثلا محرض على القتل او
قاتل هم الاشياء او ذاك الوقت انا مضطر
انه عامله بطريقه شويه تختلف عن الفنان
قال فد كلمه ممكن نتشاقه وياه عليها طلبت
بالغاء الدين الاسلامي كدين رسمي للعراق
واستبداله بقوانين مدنيه وهجمت بشده على
هذا الموضوع وجاتك تهديدات هل ندمت على
هذا التصريح لا ما طلبت بالغاء الدين
الاسلامي كدين رسمي العراق طلبت بالغاء
الماده الاولى من الدستور اللي هي تقريبا
العراق تكون عنده هويه عراقيه خاصه بدون
تحديد الاديان العراق بعده قوميات واقليات
واديان ومذاهب وكذا فالعراق يجب ان تجمع
الهويه الوطنيه وليس الدين يعني انت راجع
متاكد ندمان عليه مصر عليه
اوكي هل السخريه والكوميديا قادره على
تغيير اي شيء في الوضع السياسي اللي وصل
له العراق اي طبعا كثير من الاشياء اتغيرت
بسبب السخريه اوكي خسرت اقرب المقربين لك
اخوك ابن عمك والدك عمك وغيرهم الكثير
خسرتهم قتلا هل العلاج النفسي ممكن يساعد
الانسان على تخطي الم هذه التجارب طبعا
ساعدك العلاج النفسي مستمر فيه العلاج
النفسي والتقبل الخسارات والتقبل هذا
الاشياء اللي هي تصنع الانسان افضل انا
واخويا البارحه فقلت له انه احنا لولا هذه
الاشياء ربما كنا طلعنا يعني ما عندنا هذا
الطموح وما قدرنا نسوي شيء على ارض الواقع
فهذه الاشياء يتصنع الانسان خسرناهم
ونحبهم ولكن هي هذه الحياه
افضل اسلوب تتبعه للاسترخاء
خارج العراق من واحد الى 10 لاي درجه انت
مشهور
واحد
حاله ندمت عليها
ماكو حلقه ندمت عليها اكو مرات بعض النكات
اللي لو قلتها بطريقه مختلفه كان صارت
افضل
عنوان صحفي نفسك يتكتب عنك
عوده احمد البشير الى بغداد
صار لك كم سنه 12 سنه يلا قريبا ان شاء
الله شكرا لك يا احمد شكرا جزيلا
[ضحك]